my pillow on the verge of failing is now
trying to advertise on the David packman
show can you believe this this is a nice
little story so as a reminder we talked
a few days ago about how my pillow
according to Mike Lindell has supposedly
suffered a decline of a hundred million
dollars in Revenue thanks to a massive
cancellation is what pillow is calling
it pillow said that the box stores I
think it means big box stores the box
stores uh sounds almost like stores that
sell boxes the box stores canceled him
and so now he is auctioning off
equipment and this includes box trucks
and Sprinter vans and all sorts of
different equipment uh recently MSNBC
had an unintentionally funny segment
about this for the low
it rolls pillows right but it's not just
any industrial pillow roller it's a my
pillow pillow roller from the my pillow
pillow factory
my pillow is auctioning off more than
850 pieces of equipment from sewing
machines to forklifts the company is
even subletting part of its
manufacturing space right why
because my pillow is not everyone's
pillow or even a lot of people's pillow
all right you get the point we covered
this so all of this is going on and
yesterday I go to my uh computer
and we work with a lot of agencies that
will bring us advertisers and I get the
following message
potential Advertiser you have received
an input invite to a campaign for my
pillow for the show the David Pacman
Show YouTube my pillow is potentially
interested in advertising on your show
would you accept an order from them if
it came through and then it links to
mypillow.com and I can tell them with a
single click yes count me in or no I
will pass now in a moment I'll tell you
what I did I posted about this to my
Twitter into my threads into my
Instagram
I was stunned at the number of people
who first of all thought we might
actually advertise my pillow we've had
Mike Lindell on I think he's just
horrible in every way I of course would
not advertise my pillow we advertise
other pillows we're not doing it okay
there were a bunch of people who wrote
back to me mostly on Twitter who said
David it's a great brand you should
really do it that's really an honor and
I was like these people have to be
joking I looked they were not joking
they were very serious so that was
really weird the second thing is I heard
from many people in our audience who
said David
you're not really going to do this are
you I will cancel my subscription if you
advertise my pillow folks everybody can
relax we are not advertising my pillow
we're not advertising my pillow and I'm
going to be super honest with you
I believe that what happened here is not
that my pillow is desperate to
specifically advertise on the David
packman show I think as a sort of last
ditch to try new things my pillow hired
a new Ad Agency one of the ones we work
with and said get us on tons of shows
we've never advertised on before we've
got to do something to stem the bleeding
um and so this was probably sent out the
dozens if not hundreds of shows if Mike
you know Mike Lindell knows me if he
doesn't if he hasn't forgotten that he
knows me he can contact us directly
and just say hey do you want to
advertise my pillow it would not come
through an Advertiser I think if it was
actually them saying we really want the
David packman show so everybody relax
we're not going to be advertising the
pillows we're not advertising my pillow
but a very very interesting moment
something that's been in the news a lot
lately is data Brokers collecting vast
amounts of data about everything you do
on your phone and computer where you go
what you look at they identify patterns
in your behavior and it's really quite
disturbing how much data Brokers know
about us even our health information and
then we found out that sometimes
government agencies like the FBI will
buy that information from data Brokers
to spy on Americans without warrants ad
companies buy the data to serve you ads
financial institutions can use the
information the information can even end
up on public search sites where anybody
can see it but there is a way to stop it
our sponsor incogni is an affordable
service that sends automatic data
removal requests to data brokers who are
required by law to comply incognitive
even follows up with the data Brokers to
ensure your data is permanently gone and
incogni keeps you updated every step of
the way I using myself it is remarkable
what they will accomplish for you and my
audience gets 60 off go to incogni.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down below